salut bienvenue dans une nouvelle vidéo
casse tête j'ai pas les intros de
d'habitude j'ai pas eu besoin d'aller
chercher mais je vais inventer une intro
loïc donc bien avant qu'il n'entre au
très vite
quelle est la différence entre 3000
quelle est la différence entre 3000 et
nul
une différence et avec quelle autre
chose à quelle est la différence entre
3000 et 3003 3 donc une nouvelle vidéo
cassettes aujourd'hui ça fait un petit
moment qu'on n'a pas eue et sachez qu'il
y aura d'autres vidéos casse-tête cet
été j'ai trouvé des niveaux castétis en
sortie c'était pas mal d'arrêter d'en
faire un certain temps parce que ça
s'est un peu renouvelée au niveau des
casse-têtes originaux qui coûte une une
coiffe fortune qui sait comme celui qui
m'avait rendu fou bonne janvier ben il
coûte à peu près ce prix là et c'est
aussi pour ça que cette vidéo là sera
sponsorisé par kambly une application
pour apprendre à parler anglais que vous
avait déjà présenté un jour qui veux
aussi me finance fait un peu tout ça
comme lycée ce logo là et c'est une
application pour avoir des conversations
en anglais je vous en reparlerai tout à
l'heure pour l'instant je vous parle de
pas de lock qui m'a été offert par une
abonnée
petite anecdote de cet abonné est venu
me voir en spectacle et à la femme a
offert deux casse-tête de difficultés
extrêmes puisque c'est cette étoile sur
huit en me disant tiens il y en a un des
deux on l'a essayé et on n'a pas réussi
et du coup j'ai un autre casse-tête qui
est ici qui est complètement dépouillé
donc il faut d'abord que j'essaye de le
remettre en place dans sa position
originale pour le faire peut être un
jour mais merci à tous ceux qui m'offre
des cadeaux c'est très gentil donc tout
bloc ça ressemble à un cadenas et ce
n'est pas un canal le but serait de le
défaire évidemment après de le refaire
parce que c'était bien fait 5 à 7 qui
est refait et je suis refait et je parle
pas comme ça
[Musique]
première phase on le sait c'est
l'exploration déjà c'est un très joli
casse tête je le trouve très jolie
c'est anna maya qui fait ça anagama
d'accord gay je vous mettrais un lien
dans la description vers le casse-tête
ainsi jamais vous de chercher mais il
est très joli il est très bien fini il
est très bien produit
jeu j'aime bien par contre effectivement
il a l'air vraiment très très chaud afa
bougent un peu quand j'ai fait ça je
vois comment j'ai donc on a quoi on a
quatre pièces c'est tout à priori oui on
a deux demi-cercles amovible qui ont
l'air d'avoir d'être un peu creusé à oui
d'accord oui ils sont complètement
creuses il ya comme un rail à
l'intérieur en fait des deux de ses deux
demi cercles et ensuite il ya deux
espèces de haut ou vers symétriquement
symétrique inversée et utilisons une
bordure là une bordure là et j'imagine
en fait bon c'est même sûr d'ailleurs
oui voilà c'est ça je le vois là un
petit peu dans le trou cette bordure al
existe aussi de l'autre côté donc c'est
rentré dans l'appareil d'accord ok
et donc c'est je pense parfaitement
symétrique
ce qui veut donc dire que un petit peu
comme comme le casse tête que j'avais
avec la big et le carré autour
je pense que si tout est symétrique il
doit y avoir un moyen de trouver un
point d'équilibré où tout se
déverrouille en même temps je pense
qu'il n'y a pas trop d'étapes en fait
que d'un baroud et on va tous mourir je
reste plus qu'à trouver ça mais ce parti
loïc tu sais ce que ça veut dire pas de
locaux manquaient pas de chance non papa
de l'udc padlock non je veux dire
cadenas manière cadenas sais ce que
c'est que ça ressemble à un petit canon
à eau ont fait là si j'ai fini là c'est
c'est moche vous allez vite le savoir si
là il ya là où trop dans une seconde
c'est que c'est fini s attend à non
j'entends pas la petite musique à temps
ces problèmes et je sais pas exactement
ce qui s'est passé d'accord ok là ça ce
temps je touche à rien pour comprendre
ce qui s'est passé moi donc la merde là
ça se sépare un peu donc pourquoi vous
d'accord donc pourquoi pourquoi ça s'est
séparé un peu qu'est ce qui fait que les
puits à voir ce mouvement là parce que
là d'accord l'âge et la césure des trucs
et face à struth mais le cesu rallier
pas du tout ah ben non il n'y a pas
besoin
ah oui ok intéressant ça veut dire que
là il ya un trou ici et que la césure en
face du trou donc je peux juste créer un
décalage dans un sens j'ai l'impression
que tous venaient mais non en fait il y
avait juste ça fait juste bouger cet
anneau la halle à nos supérieurs
regarder si je fais ça elle lui qui
bouge là ok ça veut dire que si bouger
l'âge pourrait faire revenir le
demi-cercle différemment pour le pour
mettre le rail de l'huile dans lui quel
serait mon but en faisant ça eh bien mon
but serait de changer la position parce
que mon but final du coup par rapport
aux deux trous ça va être à oui ça va
être ça ça va être d'inverser oui c'est
ça ça va être d'inverser ces deux là
pour que ça soit à l'extérieur de ce
côté ça à l'extérieur de ce côté ce qui
fait que ensuite je pourrai faire une
position comme ça et oui c'est ça mon
but final avoir une position comme ça
qui nous permettrait d'ouvrir l'ensemble
du canada
mais pour ça il faut que
les deux soient complètement inversé
donc à part le mouvement qui s'est fait
un peu naturellement y apparaît grandes
possibilités
j'avais fait un truc comme ça
et donc ça c'était dans le lac ce qu'est
ce que ça me gonfle qui fait un truc par
hasard et après tu es pas capable de le
refaire en pas par hasard
donc là c'est comme ça et donc là eux
les les rails sont mis comme ça donc si
j'inverse eux ça fait exactement parce
que je voulais puisque la serre ferney
attend en fait si vous regardez la vidéo
un petit pas en arrière vous allez voir
qu'au départ on avait un trou là et un
trou là et là les trous en fait sont à
l'intérieur
du coup les deux se sont mis à
l'intérieur du rail puisque j'ai inversé
les deux rails
est ce que c'est une bonne idée ou pas
fabien ça va être très long loïc et
puisque ça va être très bon loïc je peux
pas demander un générique l'oeil
non j'ai dit j'avais dit par un
générique loïc compris donc il faut
jamais que je prononce le mot qui
commence par jets qui finit pas non ce
que je voulais dire c'est que ça va être
un petit accéléré mais pour cette
accéléré loïc numérique few sidération
[Musique]
où
je moi je n'avais pas entendu la petite
musique arriver mais on est on est on
est sur une année sur une séparation
donc du coup c'était parce que j'avais
pensé au début de la vidéo à savoir
qu'il fallait que les deux soient
l'extérieur non après il y avait une
forme de logique mais je pense pouvoir
attendre si rapidement après dire qu'il
fallait qu'il se trouve là en bas dans
cet axe et se trouve là en haut vous
voir en n'essayant pas trop bouger se
trouve la roue dans l'autre axe ce qui
fait que là ça me permet de le débloquer
juste comme ça avec effectivement une
symétrie parfaite et là vous vous dites
mais fabien pourquoi tu vas tout
doucement pour tout reposer je pense
qu'il va falloir refaire donc je fais ça
lentement donc on a cette pièce là je
vais le démonter entièrement ok donc
bien les deux rails comme je disais et
puis ça et on a cette pièce là qui est
en fait exactement la même pièce pas
exactement à quelque chose près en fait
là il ya deux pico et là il ya un seul
picot et c'est à peu près la même chose
à m après ce qui formait effectivement
le pape bloc sympa tosh c'est le 12 juin
à la sympathie c'est vrai qu'est ce
qu'on a dit
qu'est ce qu'on a dit dans la vidéo de
samedi prochain on a dit prendre la
drôle amin oui mais en même temps ça me
permet de vous dire que
exceptionnellement il y aura une vidéo
samedi prochain sur une avancée un peu
dingue et sur le rêve lucide le spoil
mondial et ça pousse en l'air bonne toi
la chaîne je suis comme un mix m
comme ça vous pouvez cliquer ici oui je
fais comme un mix m parce que lui il
parle avec son cadreur alors que moi
depuis longtemps je te parle toujours
rejetée par les bons pour des trucs très
pertinent jeunesse thème ça excellent
casse-tête blague à part je kiffe bien
j'ai bien aimé je crains par contre le
fait de le remonter parce que pour le
remonter il faut que je sois dans la
position de départ donc on verra j'ai
des doutes mais anvers avant de passer à
la suite de la vidéo c'est parti pour le
placement de produits en 30 secondes
environ
je vais donc vous reparler de kambly une
application génial dont je vous avais
parlé l'année dernière dans une vidéo
pour apprendre à parler anglais c'est
une application qui fonctionne 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7
où vous allez pouvoir discuter
directement avec des professeurs
d'anglais natif dé royaume uni du canada
des états unis et d'australie je vous
fais voir vite fait comment
l'application elle fonctionne
l'application ressemble à ça neuf mois
comme je voulais dire les professeurs de
kambly sont disponibles 24 heures sur 24
7 jours sur 7 les leçons peuvent durer
jusqu'à 15 minutes vous pouvez donc
pratiquer n'importe quand et n'importe
où avec ses sessions vous pouvez
préparer un examen d'entretien embauche
simplement un devoir que vous avez à
faire en anglais et si vous avez des
enfants dans votre entourage ils ont
lancé un truc qui s'appelle kambly kids
juste pour eux alors là vous vous dites
oui mais bon faut que j'aie téléchargé
que je paye non évidemment j'ai des
codes pour vous vous pouvez essayer
gratuitement l'application avec ce code
là qui vous permet d'avoir quinze
minutes gratuites et ensuite si vous
voulez continuer à utiliser
l'application vous avez un autre code
celui ci qui vous permet d'avoir 10 % de
réduction sur un plancher
vous avez remarqué aussi l'intérêt
double de ce partenariat
et bien c'est aussi que du coup je vous
mets pas de pub en plein milieu de la
vidéo comme je fais antara mal pour les
casse-têtes beau si vous y gagner du
coup moins de pub moins de coupes et
appartenant à des familles
s je suis débile j'aurais dû les laisser
monter dans cet ennemi commun je crois
que ces techniques comme ça alors lundi
il tv j'imagine comme ça et parce que de
toute manière il faut que ça rentre par
la fente pas blagues sur cette phrase
make non non rien quoi qu'il arrive les
rails étaient inversés donc si lui
admettons je le pose comme ça lui c'est
à dire il faut je le pose comme ça et
ensuite que j'arrive à faire rentrer ça
dans sa part eu ça marchera pas du tout
mon histoire
ça marche pas encore moi mon truc les
amis ça comme un saint c'est les ennuis
combien c'est le début des ennuis
je compte j'aurais dû plus se repérer
tout à dire comment j'avais fait pas
très très gentil non mais c'est
impossible allemands savaient donc ça la
plus grande difficulté de ce casse tête
enfin me semblait que quand je les
défaits à l'après au final cité comme ça
à temps fabien rey fait réfléchie mais
non faut que ce soit comme ça comme ça
déjà
ah non à qu'est ce que c'est marrant je
reçois savais pas que c'était sa faim là
là mon dieu mais y en a je vais trop
galérer genre lui peut-être vous avez
envie de les voir mais aussi avec à
regarder les vidéos de cet effet lui il
va être chaud mais le haut vous savez
quoi je vais les faire voir ce qu'il ya
dedans et que je ferais cet été aux gens
qui me suivent sur instagram voilà bien
qu'à me suivre c'est ici et vous serez
en avance toutes les petites exclus de
cette chaîne
c'est incroyable quel argument marketing
de fou pour vous faire venir sur mon
instagram
j'espère que tu as fait un effet
diabolique derrière sinon c'est vraiment
débile ce que j'ai fait bon et le diable
la lys y faire marc ning star est ce
qu'il va réussir à faire ça faby
s'habille le flamby mais qui s'auto
donne des surnoms tellement il a pas
d'amis d'oeil ça fonctionne ça et voilà
ça ça fonctionne ok ça fonctionne et
j'ai réussi à leur entrejeu pour trop
gourmand mais c'est pas grave voici un
casse-tête rondement menée encore encore
payer la musique tu pensais quand elle
tue ton école de cinéma que c'est sa
lettre ça après ton métier ou pas et
espère bien faire des films jazz était
patent bon là où trop c'est pour être
coincé pour être merci d'avoir regardé
les vidéos vous pouvez laisser un pouce
bleu vous pouvez vous abonner en
cliquant ici ça c'est ma chaîne
secondaire regardez là ya du lourd qui
arrive à très bientôt la semaine
prochaine mais non samedi une vidéo
bonus
bon allez ciao